music acting and now running a league
that's what ice cubes all about a
big-time sports fan and found her a big
three basketball throw to have ice cube
back here on the show how you don't you
I'm good man it's always fun to be here
I appreciate that I appreciate having
you here Friday and Dallas big three
playoff start at the American Airlines
Center home of the Dallas Mavericks and
home of the big three basketball
playoffs some of the teams with better
are in this I mean you got coaches like
dr. Jake Dayton Michael Cooper and one
of my favorites Nancy Lieberman
oh yeah Nancy she's awesome she is great
she was great for a league you know was
so happy that she took the job because
you kicked Clyde into the into the
commissioner yeah yeah I got a promotion
his league is actually doing better
under Nancy so like it says about his
coaching but yeah I mean Paulo is a
great guy Howard's a top-ranked team
coming into your playoffs here and I was
telling you this off there Nancy
Lieberman well I got to meet a few times
when I worked at ESPN back in the day on
SportsCenter
then I got to know her better cuz she's
really tight with Deion Sanders yeah
Andy on a really tight friends I didn't
know that you know until she you know we
we have our players and coaches
promoting the league and it's like I'll
tweet out that we're gonna be on this
week and she's like you want me to get
Deion to do it like the Dianna I think
you talking about yeah neon Dan that's
my man so I'm like okay yeah yeah have
them tweet so you know what's cool about
our league is it's so much history
walking around there you know you might
hear a story about the old ABA one day
you might hear a story about George
Gervin you know serving them 63 points
in 33 minutes one night you know and
it's like these kind of things you don't
get to hear you know normally you know
just walking around so it's very cool to
be a part of this live do you get
starstruck no I don't call the
starstruck I just call it much respect
you know I get ease do as much respect
and you know I'm there to take care of
them
you know I'm there to make sure that
there
happy having fun and competing at the
high level and they have all the tools
they need to win and um and so you know
setting a stage up for these guys to do
what they do you know has been a treat
for me because I'm usually the one
somebody set the stage and I come do
what I do but but it's cool to be on the
other side of that you know and I'm
taking a look at some of the players
that are participating in the playoffs
and there's a ton of great names that
are just come out at you Baron Davis
Nate Robinson Amar'e Stoudemire just
again just to name a few
one that just dumped out I'll jump out
of his mouth would Abdullah Rove yes who
you could say in many ways was the Colin
Kaepernick of of the NBA what what does
he like this he sit here and watch
what's going on in the NFL and think
that that happened to me I mean have you
ever had any conversations with him
about this I mean he's an extremely
humble man I don't think he's a guy who
who has ever felt sorry for his self you
know he's a man of conviction and I
think you know if he was the same guy
doing the same thing right now he would
take the same stand so he's a guy that's
that gets so much respect in our league
because not only is he
49 he's 14 and and his jumper is still
as wet as anybody's jumper in the league
but he is just a strong honorable humble
man and I think everybody can respect
people who are trying to lived a life
the right way you see the oldest players
yes he's always playing 49 49 and he's a
problem out there you know for some of
the you know the guys I've seen you know
really really have trouble keeping him
in front of him and if he gets an inch
he's hitting the bottom of the net if
you give him a little space he's hitting
the bottom so guys try so hard not to
give them that space cube here on the
Rich Eisen show so are you
or anybody in big three right now
combing the NBA rosters knowing they're
just knowing that this is a possibility
let's let's go after this guy for next
year or going after looking at training
camps right now if this guy doesn't make
a team we need to make a run to get this
guy in the bow yeah yeah improvement I
guess yes
our season is over in two weeks right by
the playoffs in the championship in
Brooklyn and after that you know we're
we have our eye on guys who who we've
been trying to recruit for the last two
years we're gonna go at them again and
also God knew guys that we know are
gonna retire after this season in the
NBA we want them to step off the NBA
court onto our court give me a name I'm
not giving you any names no any any any
statistics you can give me that might
give away a name I mean a hint just drop
a hint to you that it is some great
players out there that's kind of at the
end of the NBA career and we want him
and and it's something that's already
retired and we want you I saw Tim Duncan
saw you playing out there in the Bahamas
was it was the Brahmas saw you out there
playing the Virgin Islands man hey we
need you in the big three we need that
in the big three have you ever
approached Kobe yes and every time and
he always turned me now but I don't care
next time I see you Kobe I'm gonna ask
you again cuz the juices have to flow
with him still at some point I think so
you know they got a lot going on he does
have a lot going on and it may take him
another year so to get the itch but
whenever he get the itch we're here to
scratch it now it's possible to go ahead
and tell him what you just said in my
ear what do you think Kobe thinks he can
still play so he wants to be LeBron six
men this year hey I think he could do
that too if he wanted to I mean he has a
few years of rest he gets himself back
in shape why not could you imagine we
have jeany bus coming here on Wednesday
maybe I'll book a pitch that I hate the
tires on that obvious it's only
basketball yeah it's not like you know
guys coming back
to be a brain surgeon you know actor
retired yeah it's only basketball come
on LeBron so much to seeing the two of
them together it would just blow
everyone's mind I don't know why Kobe
fans hate LeBron so much because LeBron
can't do nothing to Kobe's legacy and
let and Kobe can't do nothing to LeBrons
legacy they're individuals I have their
destiny now so why are they vandalizing
murals rational because that's where the
mirror was a bit much I don't believe in
messing up art I think you just come
back for for desecrating any art but for
the most part you know saying like king
of LA before you've won one game is just
a bit much that's a bit much mister a
painter yeah there's more of the
painters fault then it's like dude king
of LA come on now the king in LA the
king is here but king of LA that's me
shows the wrong word you should add me
up there and it wouldn't be no problems
[Laughter]
when they got vandalized
yeah it'll been uh you know what they
call historical monument that you can't
touch
how about kg you reached out to him I
reached out to kg I think you know so
you know these dudes get these because
they're watching the Richards they talk
to you I know who that might be but but
you know the guys they got you know they
think they media now you know I'm saying
and uh Pierce we went after Pierce we
was this close with Pierce and he got a
damn job with ESPN and and I think he he
wants to sitting and and you know he
coffee cakes and and go to ESPN and talk
basketball come play we won't see you
back on the court I'll be amazing that'd
be fun
laughter man rich if you can make some
phone calls for me no I'll Adam there
you go
maybe there hollering at you right now
let's take a 60-second break come back I
do want to talk a little bit of you know
what's going on in your career outside
of big-three also I want to know what's
going on in any movies any TV stuff that
you're up to
I ain't doing nothing but basketball
okay then so then we got that answer but
come back there there is some questions
I do want to ask you we play celebrity
true or false we have seized some stuff
about your your movie and TV and music
career that we want to know what's true
or false okay let's do it
that's with Ice Cube they found her a
big three basketball when we come back
in 60 seconds few more minutes here with
the founder of big three basketball and
one of the greatest musicians of all
time as well as some I mean you cube how
much as gonna say this cuz you're
sitting here you are so damn funny in
these movies God Thank You Jump Street
out loud funny duh
I'm captain Dixon captain Dixon yeah in
the Jump Street is fantastic now you say
you're not you're just focusing on hoops
you're not doing nobodies pitching you
you're not pitching anybody I mean you
know I'm doing I'm doing
behind-the-scenes work I'm writing the
next Friday movies about to say yeah
yeah I'm writing a couple other things
for a universal gonna do this humbug
movie for for Netflix okay which is cool
I play Scrooge you know I don't know why
want me to play no and so and so you
know I got a few things in the works but
don't nothing the world don't exist for
this week and next week only thing
exists is big three basketball all right
and again the the playoffs start Friday
in Dallas and culminate on the Friday
the 24th that this month in Brooklyn and
Barclays Center and it can be all caught
live on Fox at 8 p.m. Eastern Time on
those Friday nights so now that all that
said and we will revisit that what did
you think of uncle drew did you see
uncle drew I just see okay I've been too
busy it came out
we second week after like our second
week
okay season so like I said man you know
when you being in sports this is
rough-and-tumble you got to be ready
sure
no I know that the reason why I ask it
seems like these players have some
serious comedy chops like they're heard
I heard Nate Robinson is is real good
everybody calling him boots he said me
he hit me I need to get boots on the
back of one of my jerseys I'm like boots
man you kryptonite what are you talking
about you knob boots kryptonite from the
slam dunk contest all right so he wanted
to be called boots so now he's boots
I mean see Webb was fantastic in this
chest what I hear I mean Shaq's go but
Kyrie he's got some serious comedy chops
it's good to see these guys showed it
the other talents you know we know I'm
you know on the basketball court and and
but it's cool when guys could show that
they got a little more in the tank
I remember Shaq used to rap and I was
pretty good I think the only only player
with a goal record so these guys are
talented now in all honesty do you think
that gold record is because Shaq was
very popular or he had gold record
talent rapping hey man you know you
could be popular you can't make them buy
it
so obviously okay you know you got
500,000 people that bought it hey it got
a count okay it got a count who's the
best athlete doing that performing
rapping hip-hop anything that you've
seen um that you would say that the he
actually or she actually has that town I
mean I think Damian Lillard is is pretty
good I'm not really familiar with
anybody else that's where I'm and like
today at level
yeah I've have you ever heard levy on
bail ever heard him no no yeah right
snoop apparently is helping him what
else don't I mean if snoop gonna help
you got a got a great shot to make some
noise yeah ice cube here on the Rich
Eisen show let's play celebrity true or
false with the founder of big three
basketball please hit the
celebrity true even it real okay this is
all from from the internet so we'll see
if these are true or false with what I
see and hold of it you actually here's
first one you actually own the Chevy
Impala that your character Doughboy
owned in boys in the hood do you still
have that car false I've never owned
that car never once know that it's false
that's false what you have wanted to own
that Chevy Impala um not really not
really no all right very good
next one true or false you have a
two-year diploma in architectural
drafting it's a true it's a certificate
and it was one year just one year one
year yep it was they crammed four years
in the one year yeah did you ever have
designs if you will I'm being annoying
detected on I mean no no I was doing it
I was into it then like the stuff we
were doing with NWA started taking off
okay and last thing I wanted to do was
be at that school I was ready to be
you're ready to take it but I brought
you know stuck it out I graduated got my
certificate and I think you know my
mother hung it up somewhere but I never
looked at that thing since which school
was this it was called Phoenix Institute
of Technology I don't even know first
aid no more piti T yep
my fake DeVry okay here's another I got
two more next one you got the name ice
cube from your brother because girls
were calling the house asking for you
all the time and that you were too cool
for your age true or false they will
call it for him it's true they were
calling for him and I would pick up you
know trying to holla at him you know I
was like man you got a big head you
don't wanna be with him you wanna be
with me I'm a little broke bro and he
found out and back in the day they would
you know if you had an old refrigerator
who put it on the curb and you know the
junkman to come pick it up and and we
had one on the curb down the street that
was there for days he was like you know
what slam your ass in that freezer I'm
gonna tender the block when they pull
you out you come to Ice Cube you know
kids die in freezers right
when I walked out the house United when
nobody to call me O'Shea number one like
my name ice cute and so it just stuck
they start calling me cute and never
called me O'Shea since last one
jheri-curl wigs used in Straight Outta
Compton were valued at $15,000 each man
I'm supposed to know about a jheri curl
with we had the real deal we did our
curls back in the day you know I'm
saying so I don't know about wigs and
how much they cost I'm pretty sure they
expensive and I've heard about gangs
going in and stealing like wigs and
extensions out of like nail shops and
hair shops so I don't think they cost
15,000 did somebody got beat some way
someone was kind of tired they needed
work well I'm just wondering if you were
produced to the film you had to you had
to okay whether the wigs were yeah
disabled or not yeah I did I did I was
really pretty anal about that because
some jheri curl wigs can look comical
and this this was not no comedy you know
so we had to make sure they look right
and it didn't look like you know the
soul glow family from coming to America
[Laughter]
so we mostly fake mostly faking yeah
yeah no real not no real jheri curl so
again the big three playoffs start this
Friday in Dallas it'll be power versus
tri-state which is Nancy Lee Berman's
team powered by Cory McGee and Birdman
Andersen and big baby Davis against dr.
J's tri-state Amar'e Stoudemire Nate
Robinson Jermaine O'Neal bonzi wells
just to name a few and then the
three-headed monsters against Three's
Company Rashard Lewis Mahmoud Abdul Rauf
49 yes geez Kwame Brown Selim
Stottlemeyer for Gary Payton against
Three's Company drew Gooden
DeMarre Johnson Baron Davis Donte Jones
for Michael Cooper who knows a thing or
two about yeah Michael Cooper definitely
he's got that team playing well
the playoffs are gonna be great you know
this is the best part of the season when
the best teams go at it and try to win
that beautiful trophy and you can check
it out on fox friday night making some
big fun not no FS one big FS one's
called tell them what you call it it
cold I don't call you know you call it
that little fox and I mean unless you
work on Fox you don't like baby this no
no we called that a man baby foxes are
sneaky about your name exactly oh man
and then again Three's Company versus
three-headed monster tri-state bursts of
power then go to Brooklyn on the 24th
on Friday night yeah for the
championship so hey everybody watch this
is uh it's gonna be great basketball
great action and fun you know we got
some of the funniest dudes talking trash
and what do you think of the Raiders
before I let you go um I don't know you
know it's like Khalil Mac it's not in a
no what the hell's what's going on with
that I mean they trade my favorite
punter and it's like I don't even have a
favorite punter I've never had a
favorite punter separate guy but you
know they traded like a king yeah he was
fun man so I don't know what the hell
was going on oh I got it I gotta get
over there now and see what's going I
can't wait to this basketball season is
over all right so I could focus on got
Raiders yeah the Raiders are a holder
minute let me get a week one the radio
that's the first Monday night Rams at
Raiders Monday night your get your
seasons way done by then I'm near in the
black hole I'm on that Monday night
there oh yeah maybe we'll have you on
after that game and yeah tell us what
you what you saw hey have a great
playoffs thank you rich come back any
time
for sure me at Ice Cube on Twitter again
check out the big three coming up this
Friday this Friday and Dallas on Fox at
8 Eastern big Fox with the finals Friday
the 24th the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience